well anyone helping to start off the new
year as a multi-millionaire has a couple
of shots at it this week
tonight's mega millions jackpot is 447
million dollars
tomorrow's powerball drawing is worth
410 million
take a look at our drone video here from
our aviator drone
lotto players lining up in prim a long
line in prim for a chance to win
now both of those prizes are among some
of the biggest lottery jackpots in the
history of this country
eight news now reporter sally hademia
was at the prim state line tonight where
people
were still waiting in line at five
o'clock how does it look now sally
that's right denise around five o'clock
we saw people still waiting in that line
they were not moving they were waiting
very patiently right now there's no more
line
as it has closed now you could see all
of that
but people i spoke to earlier tell me
they were actually here from around 8
a.m all the way until
noon so they waited a total about four
hours
now due to social distancing and only 13
people permitted
inside the store to get tickets it's
taking
a little longer it took a little longer
i should say when i first arrived here
before noon the line was around the
building
many people out here appreciated
everyone wearing their masks and social
distancing
for some this was their first time
getting a mega millions ticket
i could be a winner if i
do standing in the line for two and a
half hours to get these tickets
i could be a winner so i can think
positive i'mma claim it it's mine
i own it
the odds of a single lotto ticket
hitting one
in 290 million if you bought a ticket
for mega millions and don't win tonight
you have another chance tomorrow with
the 410
million jackpot reporting live sally
jaramillo
8 news now sally i know that you were
out there for for most of the day what
was one of the most unique answers you
heard from people who were willing to
wait in that hours long line
at a chance at a million bucks or more
than a million bucks
that's right there was many answers
denise but one that really caught my
attention
basically they were telling me how
throughout the entire year of 2020 it
was very difficult and they learned the
true meaning behind
family so they said that if they win
tonight all that money will go to each
of their family members back to you
that's a lot to go around all right
sally thanks so much for that